hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching
I'm gonna tell you something I'm very
excited to watch this movie
the idea of Shaq as a genie in the 90s
makes me like very very excited come on
over come on over I imagine that he's
gonna be a terrible actor I imagine it's
not gonna be good and I imagine it's
gonna be like kitschy is crap but I
still like I'm going into it hoping that
I really enjoy it I'm very excited about
some 90s goodness let's do it
[Music]
you
oh I cannot wait to watch a movie about
a genies Ivan magic lamp right here oh
it's not a magic lamp
it's a boombox oh how incredibly 90s
okay well I imagine there's some fun
songs in it and oh it's not singing it
it's rap okay I like rap oh it's not rap
it's rhymes
rhyming is not rapid you can't just be
like hey something's bad and it makes me
sad yo I'm really mad and aren't you
glad okay it's not not that's not what
we're thinking in high school to warm up
for theater shows we used to do rapper
up she's just singing rap songs to the
world to the Swift okay I am gonna say
something though that I think a lot of
people are not going to agree with I
love jackets I think I don't know I
think it's been enough time to like if I
saw this when it came out I'd have been
like nah man not for me not for me but
because it's been so much time since it
came out and because I knew it was gonna
be like silliest crap like I think I
really leaned into the silliness Shaq
was by far my favorite part of the movie
it was so stupid but it was it played
funny to me where like the kid oh my god
I hated that kid oh no it's so mean to
say some kids but like oh but damn if
Shaq didn't just come in and just save
the day saved the day for me he's not a
good actor but he was hilarious so the
movie is about Max who lives with his
mother and soon to live with the
firefighters that is dating his mother
and he is kind of a wiseass he's really
good at technology somehow and he gets
bullied a lot and the bullies are just
like a reoccuring like they were just
always there max gives them a key and it
doesn't work the bully is like there's
only one place this key fits max it's
like
a butthole I think that's the only
possible thing you could mean by that
sentence do you mean his Buttle are you
gonna put that key in his butthole
I am Kazaam oh yes buddy
yes you are Oh crush image I wrote I was
not expecting the rhymes definitely was
not expecting the round and he rhymes
just enough to where you're like Oh
hats making me cringe for some reason
it's very very cringy and I don't use
that lightly that term is tossed around
quite a bit but who this was uh this was
a cringefest as they say on the internet
about my videos okay so Kazaam is trying
to get max to make his three wishes so
Kazan can go off back in his little boom
box with magical shit and so he's like
come on man do you want this ice cream
in a weird way but then it matches like
oh if I don't do my wishes then I just
like oh you like a little weirdo would
do like you find out that Max's father
is in the city that he's living in he
hasn't seen his father since he was like
2 and Max is like I really want him and
my mom to be together and not Kevin
my mom's cool firefighter boyfriend who
loves her like a jerk it's pretty unfair
though I understand that you're a kid
you own your ferret story together only
makes sense but it's just so funny
because the dad is painted as such an
asshole and like man buddy you'll see
this when you're older but not all
musicians who pirate money for huge
labels are good people you know I'm
saying but that made no sense to me okay
because they are there they have this
whole concert that the the father that
like they produce the concert like
they're not like stealing the concert
like this they make the concert then the
women are singing and
then they're like well now we're gonna
pirate this music onto cassette tapes
it's like but you own the rights to it
right because they're under your label
and they stop pirating if it's your
property what I didn't understand that
at all they were like we have like a
hundred thousand cassette tapes pirate
and I don't that didn't make any sense
to me please someone explain it to me it
is a special kind of awkward this scene
is so weird the girls on stage you're
like singing - Kazam Kazam zag I don't
know I'm a little nervous but then
Kazaam just gets this confidence boost
is like all right let's do it it just
starts arriving to everyone about very
Jeany specific things he's not like
hiding that he's a genie he's like oh
yeah I'm the man with the plan
Alakazam bababa vams like he can't do
anything ethereal look I can't make
anyone fall in love that kind of stuff
he can only do like physical items and
he rhymes about don't get me down with
the ethereal in his rap like it's like
nothing people know even what you're
dogging about it's it was so funny then
you meet the villain just like a mean
guy he's like obviously the villain when
he's introduced like okay well
okay I guess there's a villain now
there's a lot of magic that Kazaam does
he'll be like oh my God look at this
french toast coming at your face and it
the effects are bad they are so so bad
then then it's revealed that Kazaam
caused Pompeii to happen the destruction
of Pompeii that got pretty dark and then
like these next sentence was max being
like what's the worst thing you've ever
seen
it's like I think I hope that it was
what he just said like he literally just
said that he caused the destruction and
so that's you're followed up with what
else is there so it's all working up to
this moment where the villain gets
control of the boombox because he's
killed max that just happens and she has
controlled the boombox and then somehow
Kazaam resists the power of the boombox
and doesn't have a master anymore and
they don't address it
he just is like all right now I'm not
gonna do this actually willed himself
out of it out of nowhere so there's no
build up to it so you're just like okay
I guess this is happening then he's like
Oh max I can't believe you're dead when
you needed me most I wasn't there man
it's like well I don't even think you
guys had that kind of like close of a
relationship sometimes it was a little
inappropriate but I don't know I just
didn't care about it all cuz I didn't
care about the kid just so mean to say
it but then the kid comes back of course
they're not gonna kill off max then Shaq
is like with the girl that he's been
hanging out with and he has to get a job
as like oh what a what a great ending a
job I can you imagine a job oh I didn't
even mention this lets green egg and ham
it no Shaq let's not green egg in here
man it's not cheesy
yeah I've never seen Shazam either you
will want to play Shaq foo after this no
entertaining but not a good movie that's
that's pretty much what I got out of it
thank you so much for watching next week
I am going to be watching Indian in the
cupboard and thanks so much I can show
you the world shining shimmering
splendid a tell me I cannot when did you
last murdered your heart decide a whole
new kind of wet food a whole little bowl
fill the kibbles now man you're way up
here on the counter I would say I'd get
off the counter that's where the real a
treat a wondrous meat for you oh shit I
didn't rhyme
[Music]
[Applause]
you